Damian est né ce matin assain
2 kilos 77 et sur ses frères épaules
déjà le poids du symbole l'ONU la
choisit il est le 8 milliardième être
humain sur cette terre 12 ans seulement
après Danica néophilie qui était-elle la
7 milliards combien de d'êtres humains
ont défilé combien sont morts combien
connaissent le grand mystère combien
80 milliards 80 milliards il y a 23 ans
le passage du cap des 6 milliards
d'individus avaient été célébrés mise en
scène devant les caméras
[Musique]
le secrétaire général des Nations Unies
a même fait le voyage jusqu'à Sarajevo
pour fêter la naissance du petit Adnan
en 2022 pas de célébration mais beaucoup
de questions et même de l'inquiétude 8
milliards
[Musique]
en France je sais pas moi je me suis
inscrit un club de tir
vous me posez une question et ça veut
dire quoi ça
il vaut mieux et oui il y a 100 ans on
était 2 milliards et la 8 milliards
d'habitants ça en fait quand même
plusieurs de trop hein
ne servent à rien
le député lf1 encore Louis Boyard a été
malmené sur son plateau il a décidé de
porter plainte pour injures publics
Hanouna lui va porter plainte pour
diffamation c'est quoi tout ça c'est une
affaire politique c'est du buzz à deux
balles c'est rien c'est quoi cette
affaire c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup de
buzz c'est beaucoup de buzz c'est un peu
c'est un peu la règle mais je dis à
Monsieur Boyard que pour être respecté
il faut être respectable ou alors est-ce
que vous connaissez une seule entreprise
sur terre dont on aurait à l'intérieur
de laquelle on aurait le droit de se
moquer de son patron sans être au moins
victimé reçu peut-être même renvoyer ça
me semble les bases des bases de la vie
entre preneuriale mais quand il s'agit
de Vincent Bolloré c'est toujours
insupportable alors que Vincent blanc en
plus ne bouge pas lui personnellement la
jamais sanctionner personne chez Lena il
aurait dû garder le contrôle mais en
même temps il avait l'impression de
recevoir comme il l'a dit entre
guillemets un frérot donc il était dans
une relation d'un petit frère qu'il a vu
grandir et plutôt affective donc il a
fait une sortie de route les injures
entre guillemets qu'il a prononcé son
pas acceptable maintenant Louis Boyard
franchement en tant que député il a
peut-être d'autres sujets à défendre que
d'aller porter plainte contre Cyril
Hanouna pour un jour franchement il joue
la Vierge et farouche là
il était payé dans cette émission il y a
quelques temps vous auriez pas aimé que
je vous dis ça parce que vous n'auriez
pas
le cadre de l'émission mais monsieur
Boyard a été payé par cette chaîne
manifestement beaucoup
c'est pas que je veux avec défendre
Vincent Bolloré c'est qu'au bout d'un
moment effectivement on nous tend des
pièges 24 heures sur 24 et moi je
faisais balance ton poste l'an dernier
il était là Louis Goyard et c'est
quelqu'un qui ne pense en fait qu'à une
seule chose lui lui est relu Joël
on est où là on est au quartier je suis
désolé moi ce que j'ai vu c'est une
petite frappe tu m'excuseras tu sors
Cyril Hanouna tu le mets dans les
quartiers où j'ai grandi ça ça s'appelle
une petite frappe je connais les gens
qui disent vas-y ferme ta gueule tu te
crois où et cetera moi c'est ce que j'ai
fait ce que j'ai vécu bon ouais ça je
veux pas faire dans quel cas il est je
suis désolé il y a aucun ami le
comportement de Cyril Hanouna c'est un
comportement de petite frappe Cyril
n'aurait pas dû insulter Louis Boyard je
lui dirai si je l'avais en face de moi
moi je suis exactement sur la même ligne
que car le livre qui était effectivement
sur le plateau hier le fait de le
regretter c'est une chose il devrait
s'excuser parce qu'il n'aurait pas dû il
n'aurait non il regrette il a dit je
vais pas aller jusqu'aux excuser ça hier
soir je pense qu'il gagnerait à
s'excuser et il aurait gagné à ne pas
perdre son calme parce que du coup ça
aurait crédibilisé je dis loutrane de
Fort-Boyard et lui serait resté dans son
rôle d'animateur pardon le secrétariat
du Père Noël vient d'ouvrir vous ne
pourrez pas échapper aux traditionnels
reportage dans les JT à partir de ce
matin les enfants juste écrire au Père
Noël ou plutôt aux 60 postiers
volontaires et aux intérimaires
mobilisés par la poste du côté de
Libourne pour répondre au courrier il
suffit d'écrire Père Noël sur une
enveloppe un pas d'adresse pas besoin de
timbre la lettre prend automatiquement
la direction de Libourne où chaque
courrier est lu attentivement chaque
enfant reçoit une réponse s'il a bien
pris soin d'écrire son adresse au dos de
l'enveloppe mais si vous voulez le
rendre moi je peux vous appeler tout le
monde frère enfin moi ma fille quand je
lui dis tu dois avancer à 22h frère
c'est tôt
chez ma mère
si vous voulez je commence tout de suite
non mais après si vous voulez devenir la
goutte moi je peux vous apprendre les
meilleurs bails en deux spi vous allez
être ça les gens
j'aime bien aussi le petit garçon qui au
milieu de sa liste de cadeaux classique
a demandé de la choucroute et des
haricots verts ces deux aliments
préférés ça c'est un chouette en
français
Théo qui reconnecte et à vous dans sa
lettre qu'il n'a pas du tout été sage et
qui demande donc au Père Noël de
transférer ses cadeaux à d'autres
enfants
revient à mon avis à cet enfant qui a
glissé dans sa lettre au Père Noël les
clés de sa maison pour qu'il ne passe
pas par la cheminée et ne se brûle pas
c'est le meilleur et vous allez Flex ça
veut dire quoi c'est la grande fierté
vous allez pouvoir être fier je vais
être Flex alors
si c'est bien
franchement frère t'as grave
je suis pas sûr que je suis vraiment
oh mais [ __ ]
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est important de se détendre dès le
matin
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'adore péter moi c'est génial